using sqlite makes it easy to delete
update it insert rows using highly
expressive queries one can even add new
columns as you revision your database
it's not a surprise that just about
every popular app make some use of
SQLite and Android it's a very popular
and important component of the Android
solution Android also provides a huge
set of helper functions to make working
with databases easy including functions
to automate query building display list
views populated by queries and even
compile statements for more information
about databases in android see the
instructor notes one thing that i wanted
to mention is that we are teaching you
the fundamentals of how to build
database in a content provider on
android the idea is that once you are
done with this class you'll have a good
understanding of how it all works even
if you end up using a library to help
build your database and content provider
and your future applications that's it
for a brief intro into storage on
Android if you want to learn more go to
developer.android.com and search on data
storage